hmm, ich habe gehört, dass du gestern danke gesagt hast
Deutschland Gott sei Dank Lord Shovets
das erste mal hast du dir soviel danke gesagt
und änderte Ihre Beziehung zu Ihrer Mutter
Ich denke
Meine Einstellung zu Deutschland war schon immer
positiv, weil ich Unterstützung gesehen habe
Gesellschaften
von Anfang an
illegale Besetzung der deutschen Gesellschaft
war ganzheitlich und zum größten Teil
unterstützte die Entscheidung der Ukraine, zu kämpfen
mein Recht und meine Freiheit und deshalb mag ich
denn meine Einstellung zu Deutschland hat sich nicht geändert
Haltung hat sich geändert
Ich denke, die gemeinsame Haltung dazu
verändert und die Kanzlerin zu mir und zu uns und
Wir müssen alle zum Kanzler Ich denke es ist
positiver Moment Ich möchte das
der Trend blieb mit was verbunden
dass es mir scheint, dass die Kanzlerin da
nachdem er Bundeskanzler wurde er
tiefer gemeistert Dieses Thema denke ich
Zuvor war er Experte für
Nun, natürlich in der Politik, aber im Finanzbereich
Bankenwirtschaft und Krieg in
Thema Krieg, glaube ich, hat er gesehen
Erben kennen keine russischen Folgen
Er sah die Folgen
Folgen dieses Krieges
Was
Präsident von Russland sagt, was zu tun ist
absolut nicht und wir reden nicht darüber
öffentliche Erklärung des Russen
Führer wir sprechen darüber, was er sie ist
dem Kanzler persönlich etwas versprechen oder persönlich
versprach Emmanuel Macron und sie hatten es
einige Gespräche dort und dann
alles ging schief, ich weiß davon
Ich denke es ist Vertrauenssache bzw
Kanzler
Ich habe gesehen, was dem Präsidenten von Russland zu vertrauen ist
Ich ziehe solche Schlüsse Vielleicht ist es nicht
Ich denke also, er hat gesehen, worauf er vertrauen kann
der russische Präsident kann das nicht
Na und
Die Ukraine hat absolut Recht, wir sind lang
klopfte an Fenster und deutsche Türen
damit sie für uns und uns offen sind
gehört dass
Wir beschäftigen uns heute nicht wirklich
mit den richtigen Leuten u
Verhandeln Sie mit den falschen Leuten
schwierig, einfach weil sie es können
etwas versprechen und sofort handeln
anders
das sind Terroristen, die nicht wissen, was
Sie wollen enden, sie wissen es nicht, weil
dass sie sich jeden Tag emotional verändern
Ihre Haltung und damit die Kanzlerin
tiefer in das Thema eingestiegen bin ich dankbar dafür
beeinflusst sehr viel es beeinflusst
Regierungsverhalten, das es beeinflusst
Uns diese Hilfe zu geben, unterstreicht dies
beeinflusst auch was
Es wird fair sein, wenn wir sprechen
darüber, dass diese Zuweisung von Hilfe nicht an uns liegt, aber
für uns alle ja das größte opfer heute
trägt die Ukraine, weil der Krieg auf unserer ist
Gebiet aber
Wohin dieser Krieg morgen führen wird und daher
Halt in unserem Land
Es tut mir leid, aber die Deutschen waren es schon immer
Pragmatiker, so kann ich sagen
problem problematisch es ist im interesse
europaweit ohne Zwischenhändler ohne
unmittelbar im Interesse Deutschlands
es scheint, dass dies die Argumente des Misstrauens sind
tieferes tieferes Verständnis des Problems
Und
Dies spielte auf dem, was heute gespielt wird
eine wichtige Rolle dabei, dass die Kanzlerin
mit deiner Gesellschaft jetzt
einhelliger in dieser Meinung bzgl
Dieser Krieg liegt in seinen Händen und er liegt in seinen Händen
und Deutschland vereinigte noch die Ukraine
zeigt seine Stärke, sondern überlebt auch
Krisen, die durch Handlungen verursacht werden
Russland
Auch Europa kann die Krise in überstehen
Stärke, wenn Sie vereint sind, wenn Sie mit sind
deiner Gesellschaft und du erklärst ihm das
passiert, dass dieser Krieg von uns allen und
wir können es alle gewinnen, aber
wir verlieren wenn wir verlieren, dann auch nicht
nur die Ukraine und Europa werden es verlieren
erfordert wahrscheinlich viel Kraft von Ihnen
Dieser Krieg dauert seit acht Jahren an
Hast du noch die Macht
Woher kommt sie
Schauen Sie, es gibt reale Umstände
wir das ist wirklich unser Zuhause zuerst das
genau das, was wir haben
Europa ist schön und die ganze Welt ist anders
schön, aber wir werden überall und besuchen
Wir werden überall Einwanderer sein, das glaube ich
Ukrainer verstehen dies wie jeder Einwohner
jedes Land, weil es nicht das erste ist
militärische Konflikte in der Welt und alle, die geflohen sind
aus militärischen Konflikten wissen, dass sie
werde sie natürlich immer besuchen
wird Europa natürlich herzlich empfangen
wird offen sein für ukrainische Bürger und
es ist jetzt offen und dafür bin ich dankbar
mehr ins Baltikum und nach Deutschland
Alle anderen Länder sind herzlich willkommen
aber wir sind immer noch zu Besuch und daher
wo ist denn die kraft zu kämpfen
jeder Mensch hat das Recht, etwas zu haben
seine zweite
wie frei du bist
Das Leben ist gegeben, es ist deine Wahl und du triffst sie
mit aller Kraft beschützen und
Eigenschaften
das dritte ist wahrscheinlich Nun, unsere Gräber gehören uns
Eltern hier Großväter Väter
Verwandte, das ist unser Land, das ist es für uns
ganz in der Nähe und hier auf den Gräbern der Familie
unser
unsere Verwandten sie sind jemand auf der Welt
deshalb ist uns diese Erde näher
lässt uns erinnern und lächeln und
Tränen sind anders, aber deshalb denke ich, dass wir
wir speichern es einfach und das ist, was wir haben
das ist alles, was wir haben, also haben wir Kraft
kämpfen Und natürlich die Hauptsache
Energie in diesem Krieg, denke ich
das, was in Wahrheit ist
Die Wahrheit ist, dass viele zu uns kamen
Jahre hintereinander wird uns etwas abgenommen
Menschen auf das Territorium und abholen geklettert
Ruhe und so weiter und die Wahrheit darin
Stärke ist, dass wir Recht haben, weil wir es nicht sind
Wir kämpfen auf dem Territorium Russlands und weiter
Territorium eines anderen Landes, ein Krieg an
Territorium der Ukraine, und das ist wahr
Die ganze Welt sieht ja jemand
Gott noch Furz noch immer geschlossen
Augen
abgeflacht Ja, aber Angst zu öffnen
Augen und wirklich Angst, es zu glauben
weil er etwas Wahrheit sehen wird
Die Menschen haben übrigens Angst vor den Rechten der Bürger Russlands
Sie haben Angst, dass sie absolut blind sind
nur Augen geschlossen und geschlossen
Ohren wollen also kein Nein sehen
hören, aber die Wahrheit ist die gleiche wie Wasser
es ist sicher eine Frage der Zeit
und deshalb ist es ein starkes Argument
für etwas kämpfen
dein Land für mich
Die ganze Welt schaut besonders auf dich
es ist keine sehr starke Unterstützung. Es ist nicht
hat das Risiko
Zu viele Anforderungen für Sie
[Musik]
sehr hohe erwartungen an euch ja ja alle
Die Welt beobachtet, was der Präsident tut
Selenskyj was soll ich sagen Präsident
Zelensky Sie hören dir zu
Ihre Argumente sind sehr wichtig. Das ist alles
Hängt von dir ab
große große Verantwortung
Dies ist wahrscheinlich die Rolle und der Anführer von jedem
Länder, weil
Leider weiß ich es leider nicht
trotzdem leider
ohne solche Herausforderungen wie Krieg bis zum Ende I
Ich glaube, das kann kein Chef verstehen
solch
die Wahl der Menschen und was sie sein soll
Präsident oder Premierminister bzw
Kanzler in verschiedenen Ländern auf unterschiedliche Weise
wahrscheinlich versteht das niemand wirklich.
Niemand versteht diese Verantwortung
was ist das zu ende philosophie drüber ja und
Krieg speziell
Insbesondere legt es diesen Nerv frei, wenn
klar klar
Was Führung ist, muss beibehalten werden
um Ihre Seite der Nation zu vereinen
damit die Nation überlebt, sagen wir nicht
über einige Vorteile sprechen wir speziell
zu den Leuten zu dieser Nation damit
es bringt die Welt und zukünftige Generationen
Wissenschaft Kunst Sprache alles dazu
Und natürlich ist es eine große Verantwortung.
Aber
Ich spüre große Unterstützung von uns
nette Gesellschaft und tapferes Militär
Ich fühle mich dadurch unterstützt
Es gibt
Das Eine oder das Andere
Stressmoment wann
Die Welt wartet auf einige schnelle Reaktionen und
und nur Siege
Das ist, weil
niemand verliert gerne und niemand
liebt Verlierer und das sind große Risiken
weil
Wow
Gewinner in einem Krieg, wenn Menschen sterben
Ich habe große Fragen, wenn wenn
Gewinner mögen so einfach wie die Menschen, die ich bin
Ich denke nicht, dass es ein Land gibt
bekam sie zurück und das ist ein großer Gewinn für
Länder Aber zu einigen getrennt
Der Mensch hat zu viel Opfer gebracht I
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher, ich fühle mich dabei
Die Ukraine hat kein Recht zu verlieren
denn es geht um was genau
Ich sagte eine Frage des Überlebens, aber ich angemessen
Ich verstehe, wessen Verantwortung
absolut sprechen
Ich bin froh, dass ich in diesem Moment Präsident bin
Zeit sie gerade
Leader Wenn alles gut ist im Land und so
weiter Du hast dich und dich gerade unterstützt
Der Support ist einerseits gut
stabiles Land und andererseits
[Musik]
du wurdest auserwählt und es muss getan werden
wir glaubten, als der Krieg gerade begonnen hatte und
sehr verändert
Gespräche international gestalten
Sie waren sehr kritisch gegenüber den Menschen, die Sie
wahrscheinlich die erste Person auf diesem Niveau
wer ohne Krawatte geht
Ist das erfunden oder alles spontan
war schon immer diese Art von Person, einfach friedlich
Zeit
Ich bin eine heterosexuelle Person, die ich immer offen bin
dachte, die Wahrheit würde früher kommen
Wahrheit ist schneller als exakt als falsch und als
und was ist Diplomatie in Diplomatie
Wahrheit und ein Anteil von etwas Arglist darin
Das Spiel ist hier, aber die Wahrheit hat am meisten
Kurzstreckenerfolg
Ergebnis oder Misserfolg, wenn es
Scheitern und deshalb habe ich mich immer dafür eingesetzt
es ist für die Offenheit der Beziehung, in der ich mich gerade befinde
Friedenszeit Nun, nicht in Friedenszeiten A
Mehr oder weniger
als es keine vollständige Invasion gab
Ich wahrscheinlich
versuchte, sich nach den Gesetzen der Diplomatie zu verhalten
und viele Dinge, die ich einfach nicht offen zeigen konnte
offen unbedingt kommunizieren wann
begann eine großangelegte Invasion
Natürlich fing ich an, mit Leuten zu sprechen
Führer
Ich denke, sie haben es verdient
hatte keine Zeit für
Bögen und auf der Linie und ich habe es nicht drauf
Zeit und Entschuldigung für die Öffentlichkeit
Diplomatie, also direkte Gespräche
kannst du mir helfen oder kannst du es mir nicht sagen
meine meinung ich werde es bei dir versuchen
Überzeuge mich, wenn ich falsch liege, sag mir wo
Ich liege falsch, das heißt, es ist immer noch ein Dialog
Dies ist kein Ultimatum, ich spreche immer noch
für den Dialog, aber ich bin für den Dialog, in dem es ihn gibt
Das Ergebnis ist während des Krieges, den ich habe, anders
Reden wir auf keinen Fall darüber
und Sie werden mir in einem Jahr antworten, wovon Sie sprechen
dieser Gedanke kam dir und mir
eine Seite oder nicht hier drauf nein
Zeit während des Krieges so ist es
der Charakter ist derselbe wie er war, aber die Entscheidung
solch
Krieg diktieren
Sie diktiert nur
Das liegt daran, dass die Zeit in jedem knapp ist
Minute kann es in jeder Minute zu einem Raketenangriff kommen
Stunde kann ein Toter sein als
Je früher ich das Ergebnis erhalte, desto mehr
Ich kann Leben retten und das glaube ich
Das ist es
Mein Hauptziel ist immer sehr schnell
reagiere auf die Situation nimm deine
iPhone und etwas sagt, dass Sie es sind
glaube, du hast eine Art Hauptquartier
welche du
Ich habe kein Hauptquartier Ich habe kein Hauptquartier Ich habe
Es gibt ein paar Jungs, die mit mir drin sind
ein Team, das sie hier beraten können
Sie können Ihnen helfen, das Richtige zu finden
Worte, wir machen es zusammen, das ist es nicht
Einzelne Menschen tun Dinge für mich
Ich sage nur nein, so ist es nicht
Meine Gedanken zuallererst, das ist entweder unsere
gemeinsame Ideen, wie wir sollten
reagieren Das heißt, dies ist ein Befehl
schnelle Antwort, aber wir beschäftigen uns
Fragen
nach all dem ist die Stromwirtschaft oben
solche Antworten von der öffentlichen Diplomatie
von all diesen
Weltführer, die Ihnen helfen werden
wer ist dir näher
Näher oder wer kann mehr helfen
anders
natürlich ist es das mächtigste Land
was dir sicher weiter helfen kann
aber auf menschlicher Ebene gibt es Menschen mit
welche
das hilft dir echt weiter
hatte eine enge Beziehung zu Johnson
schließe ihn
[Musik]
Johnson Duda
und ich konnte sie
echt und lettland litauen und gitanosu i
konnte diejenigen anrufen, die ich konnte
Anruf und Emmanuel Macron nicht immer
sagt Du rufst mich auf WhatsApp an und wir
wirklich viel mit diesen
deren Präsidenten ich sagte nein sagen
laut Protokoll schnell ging es schnell
Ich weiß nicht, was diese Reaktion verursacht hat
Ich weiß nicht, wie es passiert ist
Haltung gegenüber der Ukraine oder unserer
Beziehung zwischen uns und
bei uns ist es plötzlich passiert
hatte eine Beziehung mit einem Bagger
sehen sehr sehr so ​​aus
erscheint
Es gibt viele
Probleme während des Studiums
mikrogemanagte Kriege leider
denn im Prinzip muss der Führer
strategisch bleiben
Fragen zur Taktik und sollten behandelt werden
Befehl Krieg diktiert
vor allem der Krieg mit den Russen
mit einem komplexen großen Land hier ist es
diktiert eine schnelle Entscheidung über
als wir darüber geredet haben
Mikromanagement gewissermaßen
Es gibt Und hier geht es nicht nur um die Geschichte
die Hälfte deiner Kopfstrategie
beschäftigt sich mit Strategie Eine Hälfte des Gehirns
muss taktisch einige Schritte machen
reziprok reziprok übrigens Pay
Achtung Wir haben überall zurückgeschlagen
und bei dieser taktik ist es wichtig, wer mit dir ist
weil schnelle lieferung
politische zusammenkunft lasst uns zusammenkommen
Lass uns miteinander reden. Hör zu, sie kochen
neuer Terroranschlag unsere Intelligenz ist etwas
Ich habe dich, ich bitte dich, lass es uns tun
da deutet alles hin
ungewöhnliche Diplomatie und sogar Diplomatie I
würde sie anrufen
iPhone-Diplomatie, die es nicht gab
unser Land, und ich denke, dass dies nicht der Fall war
es gab nichts Vergleichbares auf der Welt, nicht weil
dass ich etwas Besonderes bin oder wir sind, aber weil es so ist
Der Krieg ist etwas Besonderes und ich bin offen dafür und ich
absolut gefragt jeder lass uns sein
schneller reden, nicht bestellen
natürlich schneller miteinander telefonieren
diplomatische Beziehungen haben und
Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten und Olaf
Scholz usw. Hier sind sie
Beziehungen sind so stark wie mit diesen
Länder, von denen ich gerade gesprochen habe
Ich sage, dass dies das ist, was sonst noch erschienen ist
iPhone-Diplomatie hat mir sehr geholfen
stark in den frühen Tagen des Krieges ich dudu
genannt
und nachts und
wenn ich es brauchte und übrigens oh
Präsident Biden übrigens der erste
Nach dem Angriff hieß es meiner Meinung nach
gegen 6 Uhr morgens oder 6:20 Uhr oder so ähnlich
Mein Anruf war 1 Ich meine diese
alle Länder
besorgt und chaputala besorgt aus
Slowaken brechen die Slowakei und viel nicht
Ich will jetzt niemanden beleidigen
Die Führer sind von mir beleidigt, sie sind alle gut
Wir wurden behandelt, aber iPhone Diplomatie
Niemand hat abgesagt, ich denke, es ist
Es ist klar, dass die Beziehung zwischen
führt es auch
auf menschlicher Ebene natürlich nicht nur
[Musik]
wann war
Das erste Mal vor zwei Tagen
Ich bin der erste
wir verstehen, was passieren wird
groß beängstigend
Russische Angriffe ehrlich sie immer
Sie suchen von Zeit zu Zeit nach Ausreden
Führen Sie solche Angriffe hier und eine Premiere durch
Ich glaube, ich habe nur geredet
oder oder mit Pfeife oder von Olaf war auch
einer der Ersten
Salz hier denke ich auch, dass es mir scheint
es gab ein trio von dem ersten war es scholz macron
und Duda und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr In welcher Zeit
denn ich habe nach diesem Hit u
Ich hatte 10 oder 11 Gespräche mit Führungskräften
einschließlich Justin 3D haben wir ihn auch
gute beziehungen und präsident biden
es war 10 oder 11 auf einmal
diese Gespräche hintereinander
Jeder antwortet schnell muss ich sagen
dass dies auch ein wichtiger Faktor ist
fragte nach der Kanzlerin Wie haben sie sich verändert
verändert wir alle Reaktionen sind sehr schnell
Olaf heute und das war mir wichtig
sieben G7 zusammenkommen und Deutschland
Führungsposition
[Musik]
Kopf jetzt und so ja und er
all dies organisierte es absolut
genau dort alle Länder von uns
unterstützt Nun, natürlich, wenn
Das Verhältnis der Kanzlerin war anders
Das Treffen könnte in 10 Tagen stattfinden
dies ist ein außerordentliches Treffen und das ist es nicht
war an nichts anderem schuld
charakterisiert seine Einstellung. Ich bin froh, dass
es ist eine Beziehung
Heute ist das, was ich wünschte, wir hätten es nicht getan
verloren würde ich gerne
ein bisschen mehr Europa
Europa lebt noch ein wenig damit
ein Gefühl der Angst
Und was ist mit den Russen? Was wird Putin sagen? Worüber
es wird später sein, wenn es keinen Putin gibt und jetzt
all dies und wie
Krieg in der Ukraine Fragen der Initiative
Krieg in der Ukraine Anfänge
Die Russen hatten die Initiative, wir haben uns zusammengetan
Komm schon, wir sind hier ja besetzt
dieses Gebiet ist schwierig, sehr schwierig und
inkommensurabel
die Zahl der Militärs und Mittel und Kräfte
Russische Armee und Ukrainisch
angemessen, aber wir ergriffen die Initiative
und wir rücken vor, und so schlagen sie zu
Raketen, weil ich nicht auf dem Schlachtfeld sein kann
tun nichts und sie wollen uns einschüchtern
und brechen uns gleich ein und aus
Bedrohung der diplomatischen Beziehungen
Energiebedrohungen werden was einfrieren
Frozen Europe Atomerpressung und so
weiter von der russischen Seite liegt es daran
Ihnen wurde viele Jahre hintereinander die Initiative gegeben
gab der Initiative Europa einen Bogen
aber man kann nicht auf Augenhöhe sehen
Ich sage nicht, dass der Russe hätte haben sollen
Verbeugen Sie sich, alle Länder sollten gleich sein
und schaue einander in die Augen
hier sind die Russen Jetzt musst du nur noch
Niemand wird um Vergebung bitten
Es ist, als würde man vergessen, was sie getan haben
Darin liegt die Stärke Europas
Vereint in dem, was sein sollte
Die Initiative ergreifen kann kein Land
der ganzen Welt diktieren, wie man sich sonnt
oder sich nicht aufzuwärmen und dort allein zu sein
nicht alternatives Pflanzengas
Nadel, so kann es nicht sein
Hier
wir befinden uns jetzt in einer neuen Phase
Krieg wäre ein großer Erfolg in der Ukraine für Sie
Jetzt
haben große Unterstützung
Aber es besteht keine Gefahr, zu provozieren
Russland
auf eine solche Reaktion, dass wir sehen, dass sie
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen
beunruhigt mich die Deutschen jetzt sehr
ich will das sagen
Es ist ein Risiko
hängt nicht von der schwachen Position Deutschlands ab
verstehen
wenn dieses Risiko überhaupt nicht abhängt
Europäische Positionen
Russen werden Angst haben, dieses oder jenes zu benutzen
andere Waffe wann
jeder in Europa wird definitiv
wird definitiv die Kraft spüren
Sie werden verstehen, dass sie unmöglich sind
Erpressung mit nichts
wenn bisher ein Besatzer für ihn
es muss eine klare politische Isolation geben
niemand sagt, dasselbe zu tun
das Beste, was ein Russe tut, ist in keiner Weise
weil er sich so verhält
Terroristen und Europa sollte sich nicht so verhalten
führen, weil Europa anders ist, aber Sie können es nicht
in Beziehungen dazu nachzulassen
die Führung Russlands ist bereits klar, dass er
wird ein wenig essen er wird
Nehmen Sie ein wenig und schwache Positionen ein
Beziehungen zu Russland schwache Positionen
Europa wird eben die Gelegenheit dazu gegeben
Verwenden Sie jede Waffe, die er
will, weil es keine Konsequenzen hat
er schaut auf die Folgen
besetzten die Krim und sie waren es nicht
Es gab sehr oberflächliche Sanktionen
ehrlich gesagt ja weiter gab es ihn
Die Gelegenheit besteht nicht darin
hör auf, weil du wirklich
keine Notwendigkeit gewarnt Nein, im Gegenteil, er
sah aus, als hätten sie gewarnt, ok, nicht
er wurde nicht hart als Antwort geschlagen
und das ist das Problem, auf das er losging
nahm an unserem Donbass teil
er ging, er bekam keine starke Antwort
Nichts war schlimm, diese Sanktionen waren es
Schaufenster, fuhr er fort
Sehen Sie, was als nächstes in der Energie passiert ist
für all seine Schritte nach vorne in Europa
trat einen Schritt zurück
Sie scheinen Schritte in Richtung zu unternehmen
aber wenn du sie triffst
Schritte zurück
denn in diesen Armen bist du Russland
erwürgen das ist alles, weil dies das Ziel von ist
In diesem Leitfaden spreche ich nicht von Menschen
Ich spreche davon, Menschen dazu zu bringen
leider zombifiziert
informativ Und leider ist es eine lange
Wiedereingliederungsphase
aber das ist ihre Frage, über die ich spreche
Führer und daher
Atomwaffen, wenn er sie einsetzen will
es gilt nur, wenn es so ist
wissen, dass nach der Anwendung nichts
Wille
So funktioniert es, warum die ganze Zeit
sagte vorbeugende Sanktionen
Invasion
vorbeugende Sanktionen gegen diese
Raketenangriffe, jede zu verhindern
warum hat er denn hundertmal geschossen
er ist noch nicht verletzt
und für deine Gesellschaft 100 Schüsse auf
Wir hatten 100 Schläge und für unsere
Gesellschaft Er hat das Gefühl, das Vertrauen zu schwächen
schwächelt und er kann auf dem Schlachtfeld nichts ausrichten
zeigen müssen Ausreden finden Das sind 100
hat uns getroffen
100 Schläge
vorher wurde ihm gesagt, er solle weiter suchen
Wirst du deine Leute im Stich lassen?
deine Nation hast du uns mit dir im Stich gelassen
einige Energieverträge und so
nächste Schau, du vertraust dir nicht
Wir werden nicht mit Ihnen über Vertrauen sprechen
Ende Keiner von uns mit dir
Mit keinem von uns zu reden, ist scheißegal
Vertrag, den Sie nicht wollen, zu einem normalen Preis
verkaufen
Europas Energieressourcen
Preiserhöhungen überleben nicht
Lasst uns einen Winter leben, kluge Leute versammelten sich
Der Europäer kam zusammen und entschied, wie
Helfen Sie einander nur durch diesen Winter
zusammen auf einmal zusammen nicht wie bei covid
Es ist ein gutes Land für Sie, diesen Impfstoff
Sie sind nicht gerade ein Land, in dem Sie als nächstes an der Reihe sind
Das ist nicht der richtige Ansatz. Lassen Sie uns zusammenkommen
Lasst uns diesen Winter überstehen, diese Aufgabe ist für alle
Europa und alles, und er wird dich nicht kriegen
Twist Lassen Sie uns ein wenig Geduld haben
aber niemand wird dir die Arme verdrehen
es ist wichtig Und ob er das verstanden hat womit
niemand wird mit ihm sprechen
isoliert, wenn die russische Gesellschaft
wusste, aber du hast die Person gewählt, die er ist
bedroht uns alle mit Atomwaffen
Nun, schau, er hat die Ukraine für mich erobert
sanktion und er geht auf er
droht mit Atomwaffen, deshalb ist es notwendig
eindeutig Liebe Bürger der Russischen
Föderationen
Sie haben eine Person an der Spitze, die darüber spricht
Atomwaffen über den Einsatz von Kernwaffen
Waffen, wir können nicht mit ihm sprechen und
ihr werdet alle darunter leiden
wir isolieren uns von euch, weil wir es nicht sind
mit Terroristen umgehen wollen
fair, wenn du bereit bist
Dialog ohne Drohungen ohne Maschinengewehr auf seinem
Gebiet
Verlassen Sie fremdes Territorium, wenn Sie
Dokupe, du wirst keine Menschen töten
Sie töten nur, wenn jeder von Ihnen
Entschuldigung, es ist da um es herum
Welpen, das sind nicht einmal Hunde
nur Welpen Sie werden jeden von ihnen 50 trinken
Gramm Wodka und Schreie Wir werden uns morgen bewerben
was sind atomwaffen
verstehe das
Das
sehr starke angst
Deutschland, dass sich die Menschen jetzt Sorgen um sie machen
Sicherheit was soll man sagen
Zeigen Sie nur dann eine starke Position, wenn
wird eine starke Position sein, sie werden es sein
sie werden nichts fühlen
er wird keine Waffe anwenden
hab angst deine kraft zu verlieren
die Bevölkerung wird verschlingen
Sorry für so ein einfaches Wort Nun
Die Russen werden hören, sie werden verstehen
Das ist alles, wovor er Angst haben sollte
wir sollten keine Angst haben
nicht europa sollte sich vor u europa s fürchten
eine jahrhundertealte Geschichte, vor der man sich fürchten muss
Warum hat die Welt Angst vor einer Person?
200 Länder sitzen in der UN-Generalversammlung
200 sitzen einfach die ganze Welt sitzt und
hört zu, wie man sich einer Person nähert
Es ist nur ein Mann, Mann
Du hast gesagt, dass du nicht mehr bereit bist
mit Putin sprechen
mit wem werden Sie so viel wie möglich sprechen
Beende diesen Krieg, wie kann Frieden gefunden werden
an alle, die Frieden finden wollen Wir sind bereit
sprechen
aus der Russischen Föderation, siehe ich war
vom ersten Tag an bereit, mit Putin zu sprechen
meiner Amtszeit als Präsident verließ ich
maximal an kontakten wollte ich mir alles
einige Zeit wurde angeboten
Ultimaten, aber ich konnte nicht einmal sprechen
Ich habe gefragt, ich habe alle und Deutschland angesprochen
und zu Frankreich und Amerika sagte ich, dass A
Wie wollen wir die Welt beenden, wenn Russland
will nicht einmal reden, sie wollen nicht
wollte nicht telefonieren
es war zwei Jahre vor der Invasion von zwei
aufeinanderfolgende Jahre vor der Invasion und
Sie wollten nicht, sie wollten zeigen, dass wir es nicht tun
wir werden jetzt alle reden
übernehmen und alles Und sie gingen Übernahmen
Jetzt, wo sie es nicht eingefangen haben, sagt er
Ich bin bereit, Transfers anders zu sprechen
Kanäle Ja, wer ist er? Er hat Menschen getötet
vergewaltigt die Kinder seines Krieges vergewaltigt
Kinder, sagt er, kommen wir alle auf
es können keine Ukrainer sein
gebaut, das spricht von parallel
100 Treffer in der Mitte
im Zentrum von Kiew und Sie wissen schon
Er
Das ist Nationalsozialismus in seiner reinsten Form.
Mit seiner Hand
22. Juni, als der Krieg begann
Gebiet
Kiew wurde bombardiert, wenn Sie sich das ansehen
Die Flugzeuge, die sie bombardierten, waren 20 oder 22
Phosphorbomben auf der Region Kiew Ja, und
22 Phosphorbomben waren während der Zweiten
Der Zweite Weltkrieg bombardierte eine bolschewistische Fabrik
Flugplätze
Bahnhof Bahnkraftwerk
überall, wo Putin vor zwei Tagen zuschlug
100 Raketen waren 100
für Kraftwerke für unsere
Infrastruktur war damals eine Schule
Militär Anya wurde an der Militärschule getroffen
ja Und jetzt war es auch so
Universität ist nicht anders
das ist keine andere Geschichte
einfach wünschte er, er hätte das Licht ausgeschaltet
schaltet die Hitze ab, schießt es einfach hoch
zeigt seiner Gesellschaft, was Sie sehen
was sie dir sagen, dass wir auf dem Schlachtfeld haben
kein erfolg das ist eine lüge schau mich an
Tun
er kann sein Militär nicht schwächen
Ukrainisches Militär deshalb Mann
ungeschützt wehrlos und unbewaffnet
er tötet, wenn sein Militär es nicht kann
Kümmere dich um unser Militär, dann um seins
Das Militär tötet unseren friedlichen Mann
Das ist alles einfach Pablo Nur tut er es nicht
versteht, dass ich wieder darauf zurückkomme
dass er unzulänglich ist, das versteht er nicht
Im Gegenteil, Er vereint uns
außerdem will er entweder keine
Dialoge zwischen unseren Ländern und damit
tun, oder er versteht es wieder nicht
das mit jedem ihrer Raketenangriffe
Chancen für Verhandlungen
sie verschwinden sie verdunsten es ist für uns
heute für unser Land ist
das kombinierte Bild eines Terroristen mit wem
niemand will über irgendetwas reden
sagt, so sagen wir, wie wir
Länder, die für Frieden stehen wir
Wir sagen Ja, wir werden mit Russland sprechen
natürlich, aber schon mit einem anderen gesicht
Nun, jemand wird erscheinen, eine Person wird erscheinen
natürlich wird es welche geben
Was ist Ihr Skript Wie kann ich beenden
das ist Krieg
Aber ich glaube, dass er der aktuelle Präsident ist
kann heute den Krieg beenden und
versuche dein Leben zu retten
Rückzug auf das eigene Territorium Das spricht dafür
dass es aber keine Diplomatie geben wird
dieser Schritt er er dieser Schritt als ob dafür
Zu
nur irgendwie wissen
historisch innehalten
weil sie sich in unserem Hoheitsgebiet aufhalten
niemand wird Pausen geben, nichts wird passieren und so
weiter und es wird Partisanenbewegungen geben und
das ist eine Tatsache, aber weil die Menschen auf der Krim
unzufrieden und da, naja, irgendwie er
mobilisiert Menschen und Bürger
Die Ukraine mobilisiert sie zuerst
Passiert, dann meint er sie
mobilisiert, es ist unmöglich, neu zu machen
ganz der Gesellschaft, egal wie sehr er will
das ist eine fremde gesellschaft das ist ein fremdes land
ging in ein fremdes Haus
getötet vergewaltigt und alles steht drauf
Hände absolut so Pause
er kann gehen
und hören Sie auf, Befehle zur Zerstörung zu geben
unsere leute geben befehle nachzudenken
Was macht er, schau dich an
Ich kann es dir jetzt sagen
Beschreibe das Bild und dann schaust du
sie wahrscheinlich oder nicht, also bliesen sie
Primärpfad zu einem Ja
Sie haben es vermasselt, wofür sie als nächstes
wird zuschlagen
für das Gastransportsystem der Ukraine
damit sie nicht angeklagt werden, werden sie es tun
sich in dem Gebiet, denn wenn sie
traf unser Gastransportsystem
Es ist klar, dass sie es getan haben und haben
es wird harte strafen geben
Europa schuldet Gas und so weiter, so er
Sie bliesen den Primärfluss ein
sie sprengen etwas
Wie auch immer, es ist ihr Stil, sie werden dich umhauen
etwas wird uns um zu beschuldigen
traf unseren Gastransport
System, weil sie in diesem Fall
Sagen wir, wir haben reagiert
wir haben einfach danach reagiert
wird Europa sagen, was Sie sehen, nein
Möglichkeiten, die wir dringend einführen müssen
Nord Stream 2, zu dem Sie nicht gehören
Übrigens, Sie sind Deutsche, er wird Sie sagen
Deutsche Sie müssen uns diese Gelegenheit geben
weil man sich dafür einsetzen muss
Sanktionen aufgehoben Warum Europa bleibt
ohne Gas wegen der Ukraine
das wird der Schritt sein Und hier ist es notwendig
Jeder sollte es jetzt wissen
erzählen Reportern darüber reden und
Jetzt brauchen wir eine klare Position, was wäre wenn
Russland
wird explodieren wird weiter explodieren
das Energiesystem Europas bereits, obwohl dies ansteht
Territorium Russlands europäischer Inhalt
Russland ist die Ukraine gezielt provozierend
Wir vergessen Nord Stream 2 nicht und
Sanktionen Wir sind nicht mit ihnen tun wir es nicht
wir wissen, was Sie tun werden
Es ist nicht nur, dass ich mir eine Geschichte ausgedacht habe
Schauen wir alle ihre Schritte verstehen, weil
dass A es Logik darin gibt, warum sie
sie tun Warum schaltet er die Ukraine aus
aus der Hitze wofür wofür
Kämpfen auf dem Schlachtfeld Warum bist du nuklear
den Bahnhof erobert
Warum hat er das Atom Zaporizhzhya eingefangen?
Station Warum tötest du dort Leute, die
Sie hören dir nicht zu, warum es 500 Militante gibt
auf dem Territorium von 500 Militanten Why in
als der Zweck, auszuschalten, wen Sie wollen
Schalten Sie die Zivilbevölkerung aus
Zivilisten Sie sagten gerade
alle, dass dies kein Krieg ist, dass dies eine Operation ist
Sie zerstören einige Faschisten, aber Sie
so nennst du uns, okay, du nennst uns
Sie ist ein Kernkraftwerk, das dort ist
das heißt, warum trennt er uns von
Energie es macht den Menschen Angst
damit die Leute laufen, damit die Leute
ging auf die Straße und forderte mich auf
Ich habe Putin versichert, dass unsere Truppen
kapitulierten, also unterschrieben wir bei ihnen
aufgeben oder was auch immer, ich weiß es nicht
es ist alles sehr primitiv, aber das sind Situationen
Jetzt
Sagen wir, in zwei Monaten wird es sein, was ich bin
Ich sage Ihnen, sie werden es tun und Europa
wird überlegen, was zu tun ist, wo man wohin bringt
Wärme bekommen, wo man Gas bekommt
Also vielleicht ja vielleicht
zwei weitere zwei zeigten uns an, dass wir später warteten
lass uns schnell kommen
Dieser Krieg hat die Welt sehr verändert
du siehst die Welt
in die Zukunft, auf welcher Welt werden wir leben
Zukunft
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
starke Länder, die zermalmen werden
und politische und Bedrohungen und Risiken
Wer die Welt beherrscht, ist wenn
Russland wird uns gewinnen lassen, wenn wir Frieden haben
wird aufhören und uns nicht helfen
sehr hart ja wir werden alles bekämpfen
gleich dem letzten aber trotzdem A
dann wird sich zeigen, dass es möglich ist
als ob es möglich wäre und deshalb ist es nicht möglich
nur Russland und suchte daher groß
Länder
die Welt ist in Gefahr
Sei
geografisch überarbeitet
zu Russisch
In der Welt wird es sicher eine Welle sein
große Welle Weil es mehrere gibt
solche Länder auf verschiedenen Kontinenten und
Ich sage nicht, wer Recht und wer Unrecht hat
es ist ehrlich
subjektiv wird die ganze Welt schuld sein
das erlaubte dies dies, weil
hier drüben ist es wie eine Geschichte mit
Leider sind wir heute in der zweiten Welt
den Krieg als Geschichte mit den Tschechen zurückzugeben
gab Hitler ein wenig nach, gab ein wenig nach
und es ging weiter, es wird dasselbe sein
nur im globalen Maßstab führt
natürlich zum weltkrieg natürlich
deswegen denke ich ist das so
Welt Welt der großen Monopole sein solches
Monopole, aber hier geht es nicht mehr um Gleichberechtigung
richtig Sie werden nur gleich sein
Rechte und Freiheiten in jedem präsentieren
Land keine kleinen Länder erwürgen
kleine mittlere große große Länder
wird diese Welt teilen
so könnte es sein
Vorgeschichte wann
jeder Mensch auf dem Planeten Erde wird
wissen, dass es egal ist, was es ist
Land, egal was ihr
Waffen, unabhängig davon, ob es sich um Nuklearwaffen handelt
Waffen oder nicht Sie haben die gleichen Rechte und
Sie sind genauso geschützt wie alle anderen
Mann der Welt und
Das bedeutet, dass es ein Beispiel gibt
Ukraine was
Egal wie groß Russland ist
Die ganze Welt wird sich für dich einsetzen, wenn sie
Rechte verletzt
Menschenrechte
Das ist es, das ist es, zwei zwei, ich denke das
das sind die beiden Endungen
Was ist besser? Nun, ich verstehe, wenn ich mich anlehne
Modelle der Gleichheit der Rechte und Freiheiten Vot Aber
Die Welt entscheidet, wie sie lebt
Noch ein kleines Dankeschön zum Schluss
Frage Ich sehe dich jedes Mal in dieser
T-Shirt wie viele Ich habe viel Wie viele
Stücke 20
Weißt du, warum ich dir sage, ich hatte
War
Ich hatte zu Beginn des Krieges zwei T-Shirts
Ich hatte zwei T-Shirts und
so ein Vlies Vlies
und dann sahen sie, dass das Militär zu mir wurde
reichte mir ein T-Shirt I
von Sekunde zu Sekunde vielen Dank gesagt
die dortigen Brigaden übergaben später noch eine
begann unser Ukrainisch
Hersteller Modedesigner sagten nichts
Nein, wir wollen nur, dass Sie es tun
Ziehen Sie unser T-Shirt an, hier sind wir vor Ort
Der Hersteller sagte ok und dann sie
Sie gaben mir, ich habe sie schon alle gestoppt, aber
jeder wollte sein T-Shirt haben
war auf mich, naja, und irgendwie
Im Allgemeinen habe ich mit Kleidung keinen Mangel